المترجم: Hiba Moukaw
المدقّق: Lollia Shaban
آلو، آلو، السلام عليكم
لو سمحت أريد متحدث لـ TEDxShihar،
نعم، يوم السبت، لا في التحفيز
لدينا الدكتورة إسراء.
النفايات المعلوماتية!
آه، هذا جزء من التضليل الإعلامي
عند حسن رحمن.
أريد شيئاً يخص التكنولوجيا،
ابحث لي عن شيء بهذا الخصوص.
تطبيقات! حسنًا، أنا في انتظارك.
لا، الدفع عند الاستلام، ليس الآن.
شكرًا لك، سلام.
مساء الخير.
أنا سلطان المنصوري،
أسعدني أن أكون معكم الليلة في TEDxShihar.
قال لي الزملاء: ممنوع أن تخرج دون جوال،
هذا النظام للكل.
قلت: استثناءً، زميل لكم في اللجنة؟
قالوا لي: استحي.
قلت لهم لا أتنازل، لأن حياتي كلها
مرتبطة بالجوال.
إلى أن حاولت التواصل مع شخص
(طرف ثالث) ليوفر لي متحدثي TEDx.
سنرى!
اليوم سأتحدث معكم
عن الطرف الثالث في حياتنا.
فكرة الطرف الثالث هي:
إذا راقبت جوالي،
ما هي أنواع التطبيقات الموجودة فيه؟
لكن، يجب أن أفكر وأحلل،
لماذا هذه التطبيقات موجودة في جوالي؟
في جوال الدكتورة وجوال الدكتور
وجوالك وجولاتكم جميعًا،
بجميع جوالتنا موجودة هذه التطبيقات.
ما هو السبب الرئيسي الذي
يجعلها متوفرة داخل أجهزتنا؟
ما هي عوامل النجاح
التي جعلتها تتوفر في جميع الأجهزة؟
وبينها منافسة؟ وحققت نجاحات عظيمة؟
فهذه التطبيقات تبدو لي أنها ظاهرة،
تقدم خدمة وليست معرفة أو معلومات.
ظاهرة التطبيقات الخدمية.
الفكرة الأساسية فيها: - وهذا جنون -
أن تقدم خدمة لا تملكها من الأساس.
هذه دهشة.
أجلس متأملًا، أريد غرفة بالفندق
بدلًا من أن أتواصل مع الفندق،
أو الشقة أو المنتجع أو الشاليه.
أذهب لـ "بوكينغ دوت كم".
أذهب لـ "غودا"
بينما "بوكينغ" لا يملك أساسًا
أي غرفة واحدة حول العالم،
لا يمتلك فندق واحد حول العالم.
أريد أن أطلب من مطعم
أتواصل مع "هنغرستيشن"
لن أطلب من "ماكدونالدز" مباشرة.
لماذا؟ ما هو السبب؟
أريد معلم لغة إنكليزية،
أذهب لـ "كامبلي"
ليوفر لي معلمين،
لكنه في الأساس ليس لديه معلم واحد.
لا يمتلك أحد.
هذه الفكرة تجعلك تدرس التطبيقات.
وليس مجرد استخدامها.
لماذا هي طرف ثالث؟
سنرى!
هذه بعضها "أوبر"، "مهارة"
وهو يقدم عمالة، صيانة منزلية، كهربا، سباكة
تطلبها أون لاين، تحددها
وهو لا يمتلك أيّ عامل صيانة.
"هنغرستيشن" طلبات الأكل، "بوكينغ"،
"كريم" "كامبلي" لتعليم اللغة الإنكليزية.
السبب الذي يجعلنا نلجأ للطرف الثالث،
أو نثق فيه؟
لماذا لا نطلب مباشرة من الأساس؟
أي لماذا لا أذهب لمطعم معين؟
أو لماذا لا أذهب إلى فندق؟ أتواصل معه؟
أتواصل مع معلم؟ مع عامل؟
ما السبب الرئيسي فيها؟
لماذا لا أذهب مباشرة رأس برأس؟
هذه الأسباب، أو قد تكون هذه بعضها،
لأنني اجتهدت وحاولت أرصدها وأحللها.
أولاً: انتشارها.
فأنا أجد "هنغر ستيشن" بكل مكان.
"بوكينغ دوت كم" منتشر حول العالم،
يوفر لي خدمة، أجد في قائمته
المئات من المنتجات التي أحتاجها.
"سوق دوت كم" الشيء ذاته، و"في آي بي".
وفي "أمازون" أريد كتابًا واحدًا،
أجد خيارات متعددة بالنسبة لي.
تنوع الخيارات: لم يعد لدينا مأزق خيارات
كالذي تحدثت عنه الأستاذة يارا.
تسهيلات الدفع: أنا ممكن أدفع بالفيزا كارد،
ممكن أدفع بـ"مدى"، ممكن أدفع نصف المبلغ،
أو الدفع عند الاستلام
كما قال المتحدث السابق.
التخفيضات والنقاط: تعطي الجهات
كوبونات (كوبون تخفيض).
أو تعطيك نقاط أنت تجمعها وفق عملياتك معها.
أخذت الحجز هذا، ستنتقل إلى المرحلة التانية
فهي عبارة عن مراحل أنت تستخدمها.
الفواتير الإلكترونية: وهذه تفيدنا
في ميزانيتنا كثيرًا.
في ترتيب حياتنا،
تصل الفاتورة جوالك، أو على الإيميل مباشرة.
فأنت لست بحاجة لجمع الفواتير
يدويًا أو ورقيًا وتحتفظ فيها.
خاصية المتابعة: أنا طلبت المتحدث قبل قليل،
أستطيع الآن أن أتابع
مع الطرف الثالث هذه المنصة.
هل طلبي جاهز؟ أم أنه تحت الإجراء الآن؟
أو أنه في طريقه للتوصيل؟ أي من الممكن
أن يدخل علينا متحدث جديد بعد قليل
هنا على المسرح.
فهذه الفكرة أنها
خاصية متابعة لطلباتك من المطعم،
من "بوكينغ دوت كوم"،
مع معلمك.
أنت ترى ترتيباتك،
أنت تجلس تتابع أمور حياتك
بضغطة زر من هذه التطبيقات.
الدعم: الدعم الفني الموجود فيها
على مدار الأربع والعشرين ساعة.
والأساتذة هنا في الهندسة
والتقنيات المعلوماتية يعرفون أهمية
هذه النقطة.
أنا في حياتي لا أريد أن أتعطل.
أريد أن أتواصل مع تراجم.
أريد أن يستجيب لي خلال ساعة،
وساعة كثير، كارثة الآن في عالمنا.
الاسم الذي صنع له قوة:
لو كان لدينا شركة سيارات أجرة
أو سيارات توصيل في الطائف
ناشئة أمس.
مين سيتعامل معها؟
بينما بوجود اسم قوي "كريم"، "أوبر"
له ثقله وله موثقية
عندي أنا في التعامل معه.
لماذا تتعامل الجهات مع الطرف الثالث؟
أنا عندي مطعم، أو فندق
أو أنا مدرس لغة إنكليزية.
لماذا لا أذهب مباشرة
إلى عميلي الذي أحتاجه؟
أنا عندي هنا.
هذه أشياء لوجستية، في الدعم اللوجستي.
أنا عندي المنتَج وعندي المستفيد،
لماذا لا أذهب مباشرة؟
لماذا أحتاج وسيط؟
لماذا طرف ثالث؟
هذا الطرف الثالث يوفق
رأسين بالحلال.
لكن بطريقة تقنية طبعًا.
الهدف أن يساعد في الانتشار.
أنا صاحب مطعم، سأجد
إعلاناتي في "هنغرستيشن" دائمًا.
مجرد ما أرى الاسم
في "هنغرستيشن"،
إذًا، هذا خيار أمامي واضح،
هذا منتج أستطيع أن أثق به.
أدخل "بوكينغ" أجد شققًا معينة
في الطائف مثلًا، شهد الطائف
التي يقيم فيها الزملاء.
أجدها على الموقع، أنا أثق فيها.
ثقة متبادلة: أنا أثق في "بوكينغ".
"بوكينغ" يثق في الجهة
الثانية في تعاملاتهم.
أنا أثق في "هنغرستيشن"
"هنغرستيشن" يثق...
فهذه الثقة المتبادلة بين الأطراف الثلاثة.
يخفف من التكاليف، أمور مالية كثيرة
التي يخفف منها.
ويخفف من أعباء ويخفف من مهام،
فبدلًا من أن أجد موظف
دعم فني وموظف تقنية المعلومات،
وموظف للموقع وآخر للتطبيق ومحاسب.
لا، أنا نهاية كل شهر يصلني مبلغ في حسابي،
الدعم الفني عندهم، المتابعة عندهم،
أنا مرتاح من أعباء كثيرة.
هذه إحصائيات، مدهشة
لبعضنا ومزعجة لبعضنا الآخر.
لكن دعونا نستمتع!
وشاهدوا حجم الدهشة فيها.
"بوكينغ دوت كم" يتم حجز أكثر من
1.550.000 غرفة يوميًا.
"سوق دوت كم"
23 مليون زائر بشكل شهري.
"كريم" أكثر من 13 مليون مستخدم.
أي نصف عدد سكان السعودية، أو أكثر.
"ايبي" 180 مليون بائع
نشط - من إحصائية ايبي لعام 2018-
"أوبر" متوسط 17 مليون رحلة يوميًا.
لا تقولوا لأحد (ضحك).
ما هو المطلوب؟
أنا كنت أفكر في المطلوب،
لكن جلست أستذكر.
هناك شاعر عظيم يقول:
"وإني وإن كنت الأخير زمانهُ
لآتٍ بما لم تستطعه الأوائلُ".
الموضوع عندك وعندكِ
وعندكم جميعاً
ما هو المطلوب؟
الآن هذا وقت المنصات،
وقد يأتي وقت منصات المنصات.
ما هي الجهة؟ ما هو القطاع
الذي نستطيع أن نحقق
أو نوفق فيه بين رأسين بالحلال؟
أتمنى ليلة سعيدة لكم جميعًا.
(تصفيق)